The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
So today the idea
is to think about CT systems
in exactly the same way
that we thought about
DT systems last time.
For the past couple
of weeks, we've
been looking at many
representations of both CT
and DT systems.
Last lecture we made a picture
of a bunch of different ways
to think about DT
systems and we tried
to think about
relations between them.
The new thing from
last time was this idea
of a z transform, which formally
is the link between a system
function, a function
of z, and a unit sample
response, a function of n.
We showed last time
that because we already
understand a whole lot of
these other connections
that connection is
very straightforward.
What we're going to
do today is precisely
the same thing for CT.
The boxes barely changed.
You should see the
relationship immediately
between the former set of
boxes and this set of boxes.
And we'll do a
very similar thing.
We'll look at a relationship
between the system
function, which is
a function of s,
and the impulse response,
which is a function of t.
We'll look at that
similar function for CT,
the thing that's analogous
to the z transform in DT.
So Laplace transform,
just like in DT
where it maps a function
of time to a function of z,
here it maps a function
of time, which in CT we'll
write that way.
It maps that to a function of s.
So s is going to be
something like x of t
e to the minus st dt.
So the idea is going to be that
this was a function of time.
This is only a function of s.
We get the function
of s by integrating
some function of time,
but we integrate time out
so time disappears.
So the idea then
is that we end up
with a map linking a function
of time to a function of s.
Presumably you've
seen this before.
This is a topic in 1803.
Smile.
Nod your head.
Make me feel like I'm
connecting to you, right.
Right, so you've all
seen this before.
Nothing's new.
Actually there is one
tiny thing that's new.
In 1803 they use a
variant of the Laplace
transform that we will
call the unilateral Laplace
transform, which means they
started their integrals at 0.
For reasons that will be clear
at the very end of the course,
when we do Fourier
transforms to make
the transition between this kind
of a transform and a Fourier
transform easier we
will do something
called a bilateral transform.
The only difference being that
we will start our integrals
at minus infinity.
There are subtle differences
between those two transforms.
Rest assured, that the
big picture is identical.
And when there is an
important difference
we will point that out.
So for the rest of today and
for the rest of two weeks
I will only talk about
bilateral transforms, the kind
that we integrate
over all of time.
And the easiest way
I know to get started
is to just try some, right.
You could study
properties of the math.
That's probably the way
it was studied in 1803.
I find it easier to develop some
intuition for what's going on
here by just doing some.
So here's probably
the simplest Laplace
transform we'll look at.
What's the Laplace transform
of a function of time
that exponentially decays
with positive time in a 0
for time less than 0?
As you might expect, the
first transform we'll do
involve simply plugging
that mathematical formula
into the definition.
So the x of s, the
Laplace transform,
is always the function of
time integrated against e
to the minus st.
We're only doing
bilateral but notice
that the 0 for t less than
0 cuts off the bottom.
So in fact, you would
get the same answer
if you did bilateral
or unilateral.
And then we're left with
running this integral
over infinite time this kind
of a function, which comes out
looking like this.
The only tricky thing is
thinking about the implications
of that infinity thing.
There's going to be certain
values of s for which
that integral diverges.
So to think about that,
think about the thing
that we're integrating.
We're integrating something
that looks like e to the pt.
We're integrating
against some function.
So define the original function
of time is e to the minus t,
here we have e to the
minus st. Let's just
focus on that one for a
moment, the e to the st thing.
We're going to generally be
worried about values of s,
or here, values of p,
that have complex values.
We're going to be looking
at the s plane just the same
as last time we
looked at the z plane.
So we're going to think
about this thing might have
a real and imaginary component.
So we might have something
like looks like this.
Sigma would be the
real part of p.
Omega would be the
imaginary part of p.
And somebody want
to hazard a guess
at what that might look
like if I tried to expand it
as a real and imaginary part?
Someone wanted to hazard
a guess at the name
of the equation I might use?
AUDIENCE: Euler.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Euler's equation, sure.
So I would expand this
by Euler's equation
and I get something of
the form e to the sigma t,
cos omega t plus j sine omega t.
The point of writing
that out is that I
hope it's clear that
convergence of the integral
is going to depend critically on
the real or the imaginary part?
Real, right?
So the convergence is going
to be determined by this.
This is the thing that's
affecting the magnitude.
That's the thing that's
getting smaller or bigger
as I go to infinity
or minus infinity.
The cosine term, the sine
term, those are oscillating.
They don't make the function
be more or less convergent
than it was or originally.
So when I'm thinking
about convergence
I'm going to be thinking
about the real part.
So over here if I want to
make this integral converge
I want to be thinking about
t going from 0 to infinity.
Well, 0 is not a problem.
e to the 0 is 1,
that's going to work.
It's the infinity
part that's a problem.
So if I have infinity
plugged in for t,
what's the range of values for
s for plus 1 that makes sense?
That's the important
question, right.
So I'm going to
want to constrain
the real part of that number,
s plus 1, to be bigger than 0.
If the real part of that
number is bigger than 0,
then this thing
will converge to 0.
If that converges to 0 then
I have a simple answer,
it's just the answer
in the bottom.
It's in the bottom so I have
to put a minus sign, that
kills that minus sign.
So my answer is 1 over s plus 1.
Easy, right?
And we will say that the Laplace
transform has a functional
form, 1 over s plus 1.
And it has region of
convergence, the real part
of s bigger then minus 1.
Just solving that inequality
for the real part of s so
I can draw it on an s plane.
So we'll associate
then with this
s transform a picture which we
will commonly call the pole 0
pattern.
Is just a picture
of the s plane which
shows me the singularities, the
poles and zeroes of the Laplace
transform and the
region of convergence.
So there's a single pole.
There's a pole at
s equals a minus 1,
so I indicate that by the x.
And I have region of convergence
which I'll illustrate here
with the gray area.
So it converges for all values
of s that are in the gray area.
OK, easy right?
Trivial.
OK, so now you get to
talk to your neighbor.
OK, turn to your neighbor.
Say, hi.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
And figure out the
Laplace transform
of a slightly more, but not
very complicated, function.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
what's the answer?
Everybody raise your hands,
show some number of fingers
equal to the number of
the correct solution.
Wonderful.
The universal answer-- I think
it was universal-- was 1.
So how do you get 1?
What do I do?
How do I find the Laplace
transform of the top function?
[INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Precisely.
So what I do is just stick it
in the formula, do it twice.
Laplace transform, like
the z transform, is linear.
It will turn out that
the Laplace of a sum
is the sum of the Laplaces.
If I simply stick the expression
for x2 into the definition,
you can see it splits
into two pieces.
And I get two parts.
1 over s plus 1
just like I got--
so the first part looks just
like x1, the first example.
The second one looks
almost the same
except there's a 2 where
there used to be 1.
Shockingly, it changes
one of the ones into a 2.
And then the only issue is where
is the region of convergence.
So this part converges
if the real part of s
is bigger than minus 1.
This converges if the real part
of s is bigger than minus 2.
So they both converge
if the real part of s
is bigger than minus?
AUDIENCE: 1.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 1, right.
If I'm in the region of s
where both the first part
and the second part
converges then I'm fine.
So that was all very
straightforward.
I get an answer that
was number one, OK.
So the transform is just
the sum of those two pieces.
And the region is the
region of overlap.
A more interesting
case, and where
things are a little
bit different when
we think about the
bilateral Laplace transform
than unilateral,
is that the regions
can be more complicated.
So here's an example where
I've got a backwards traveling
function.
So now the function only
exists for t less than 0.
As you might expect, just
stick it in the formula
and see what happens.
So stick this
expression into here.
Now it lips off the
top of the integral.
But when you're grinding
through integrals
it's hard to tell
the difference.
You get something that
looks very much the same.
The thing that is different,
notice that the function
was upside down.
It was minus something
rather than plus something
like the first example was.
So the first example was e to
the minus t, t bigger than 0.
This example is minus e to
the minus t, t less than 0.
That gave me a minus sign
here but the nontrivial limit
is at the top rather
than at the bottom.
That's the reason I
put the minus sign in.
So it would kill the
other minus sign.
Also, since I need convergence
at t equals minus infinity,
the region flips.
I still need to have
that sort of thing decay
so that the integral exists.
But now the functions
are flipped in time.
So the important range
of s is now flipped.
So now I get the same functional
form exactly, but a region
that's on the other side.
That's one of the
central differences
between the bilateral and
the unilateral transform.
I need to tell you the
region of convergence
for you to know which
of those two functions
that I'm talking about.
OK, so the important
thing from this example
is the functional form
looks exactly the same.
I had a functional form
in time, e to the minus t,
e to the minus t.
It was that functional
form of time
that I crank through
the integration for,
and it's not
surprising then that I
get a functional form for the s
transform that looks the same.
If you start with functional
forms in time that
look the same, you get
functional forms in s
that look the same.
However, since the
region of t was
different for the two functions
the region of s is different.
There's also the negative sign.
There's the fact that
this flipped this way,
and that's related to the fact
that my region of integration
extends from minus infinity
to 0 versus 0 to infinity.
The important limit flipped
from being the bottom limit
to the top limit.
OK, that's roughly it.
So just to make sure that
everybody is with me,
what's the Laplace
transform of this symmetric
looking function?
So which of those functions
is the Laplace transform
of the symmetric function?
It's about 3 calories to
raise your hand, right?
Good exercise,
makes you breathe.
The answer is?
Oh, come on.
OK, it's more like 90% correct.
So not everybody has it right.
What am I going to do?
It's just like the
last one, right?
Just stick it in.
If you think about writing
the integral of this
the complicated part is this
absolute value sine thing.
So split it into two parts,
that way the absolute value
is one thing when
t is bigger than 0
and it's a different thing
when t is less than 0.
Now looks like just the
sum of two functions that
are both trivial.
One is right sided, the
other is left sided,
so we might be expecting
something a little funky
compared to the last one.
So this guy that is
left sided in time
ends up with a
left-sided transform,
just like the previous examples.
So we see that this
part, which looks
like a pole at 1, so
we're going to get
a part of the transform
that has a pole at 1.
And it's going to be valid
for regions in s space
for s magnitude less than 1, OK.
Then we're going to get
this other piece, that
corresponds to a pole minus 1.
And it's right sided, so
like the right sided examples
that we saw before
there's a right sided
region of convergence here.
So it's going to be right of its
pole, but it's pole is minus 1.
So in sum, the
region is going to be
to the right of the
pole at minus 1,
and to the left of the
pole at 1 because we
have to be in the
part of s space
where both of those two
integrals converged.
So we end up with the ROC
being the intersection, OK.
So we get a pole 0 pattern
that looks like this.
There are two poles now.
When you add
together a part that
looks like a pole a
minus 1 and a part that
looks like a pole at
1, you get two poles.
And the region becomes
the band in between.
Again, because the
regions of s transforms
because of Euler's
expression is determined
by the real part of s.
So that we're always going to
get some kind of vertical band.
The band is always going
to be delimited by a pole,
just like it was
in a z transform.
There's two poles.
So all we really
need to worry about
is which region
bounded by two poles
we're going to correspond to.
OK, so the answer was two.
Written in a little
bit of a funky form,
but if factor this you can
see that there's two poles,
one at 1, and one at minus 1.
So hopefully that's all
trivial, that's all stuff
you can do in your sleep.
What I want to do is
think a little bit
about what the implications are.
What are we doing?
What is a region of convergence?
So I want to think now about
four different functions,
in four different
poles zero patterns,
in four different regions.
And I want to think about
the defining integral,
that one up there.
I want to think about x of s is
the integral over all of time
of x of te to the minus st dt.
What are we doing when we
take a Laplace transform?
And what are we
doing when we specify
a region of convergence?
Because I can help
you think about
what should the answer
be, which is helpful
when you're trying
to think about
does my answer make any sense?
Or what am I doing anyway?
So x1, this was
e to the minus t.
So it had a pole at minus 1
in the region to the right.
Right-sided function,
right-sided region.
Here we have a more
complicated function,
which can be the sum
of two poles, one
at minus 1 and 1 at minus 2.
And we got a region
that was to the right
of the rightmost pole.
Right-sided function,
right-sided region.
Here was x3, which was the
negative part of that one.
We got the same pole minus
1 one the left-sided region.
And here was the symmetric
one where we found
that the region was in between.
So what I want to
think now is what
happens when we have a
particular value of s that
is inside or outside
those regions.
What's really going on?
So let's start by
thinking about what
would happen if I considered
an s depicted by this red x.
I probably shouldn't
have used x.
I should have
probably used a star.
That's not a pole.
That's the value of
s in this integral.
What happens if I choose to
integrate against the function
e to the minus st where s is 0?
If I choose to integrate
against that function,
that function as
depicted by red here.
So the convergence
of the integral,
the convergence of
the thing that I'm
calling a Laplace
transform depends entirely
on the convergence of x.
That's what s equals 0 means.
s equals 0 says, the
converge of the transform
depends entirely on the
convergence of the function.
So that means that this
function converges,
it's in the region
of convergence.
This one converges, it's in
the region of convergence.
This one does not converge,
this one diverges.
As you go to minus infinity
the function is unbounded.
The transform doesn't exist.
s equals 0 is not in the region.
That's what it means.
Here, if I integrate against e
to the 0 both sides converge,
there is no problem.
I'm in the region.
So now if I think about a
different s, what if I move
s a little bit to the left?
Say, minus 1/2.
If I'm thinking about
integrating against e
to the minus st, and
if s is minus 1/2,
that's e to the 1/2 t.
e to the 1/2 t is a
function that for all time
becomes greater as I go
toward positive infinity,
exponentially greater.
So if I think about what happens
if I multiplied this x of t
by that weighting
function, does the product
converge or diverge?
It converges because the
convergence of the blue line
is faster than the
divergence of the red line.
Even though the red
line is diverging,
the product is
overall convergent.
OK that's because of
the relative positions
of the red x and the blue x.
The blue function is converging
faster than the red function is
diverging.
The product converges.
So this x is in the
region of convergence.
That's what it means.
Similarly here,
this is diverging.
The red curve is
still diverging.
It's the same red curves
are all these red curves
are diverging to the right.
This one is converging.
It's ultimately converging
as the sum of two things, e
to the minus t and e to
the minus 2t, both of which
are fast compared to the
explosion e to the 1/2 t.
So I'm in the region.
Here it's exploding
in a region of time
that I don't care about.
And it's convergent
for this region of time
that I do care about, but
it's not convergent enough.
So the integral still diverges,
I'm not in the region.
And finally, this one
is more complicated.
The integrand, this thing
that I'm integrating against,
it's always becoming greater as
I go toward positive infinity.
That tends to be
convergent on this side
and divergent on that
side, but it's not
divergent enough to make
the function not converge.
So I'm in the region.
If I make an even bigger pole.
So say I put e to the st, if
I put that at minus 1 1/2,
then that is fast enough
that it breaks the product.
The product is no
longer integrable.
So this divergent trend is
enough to make that diverge.
I'm not in the region anymore.
Similarly here, I'm
not in the region
because I've made it fast enough
that one of the parts diverges.
One of the parts
coverages, but they
have to both converge in order
for the interval to converge.
Here, I have finally
made the left-hand side
convergent enough to make
the product converge.
So that's fine.
And here, this is
accelerating so fast
that although it
was stabilizing here
it became non-convergent
over here.
What I want you to get
from this is the idea
that you can think
physically about what
the region of convergence is.
The region of
convergence is a function
that I stick into the integral
to make the integral converge.
So the region of
convergence corresponds
to those exponents that
makes sense for which
the integral will converge.
OK, with that vast new insight
this problem is now trivial.
Enumerate all possible
functions x of t
for which that's the transform.
So how many functions are there?
Keep going, keep going.
I'm still looking
for a right answer.
That's a clue.
Right, I don't see
a right answer yet.
So keep going.
Keep going.
Actually, I do now.
I see two right answers.
Can we make it three?
Going once.
Going twice.
Two right answers?
OK, the right answer is three.
So now that I've told
you the right answer,
you rationalize for me why
is the right answer three?
Talk to your neighbor.
Why is the right answer three?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK, who can volunteer
a concise statement
for why the right answer
is three and not four?
Yes?
[INAUDIBLE]
That's exactly right.
There are two
poles, and there are
three ways you can divide
up the s plane by two poles.
So there's four functions
here, let's think about four s
planes.
So each of these functions--
so here's a pole at minus 2.
Here's a pole at 2.
Minus 2, 2, minus
2, 2, minus 2, 2.
They all have the same poles.
OK, where's the region that
corresponds to function one?
So here's pole at
minus 2. e to the minus
2t corresponds to
a pole at minus 2.
u of t is right-sided function.
Where's the region
that corresponds
to the pole minus 2?
To the right of minus 2.
So this first function converges
to the right of minus 2.
This function is a pole at 2, e
to the 2t and it's right sided.
So it's right sided with
regard to a pole at 2.
So what's the region
that corresponds
to a right-sided
time function that
corresponds to a pole
at 2, or that's right
sided with regard to here.
So the net region of
convergence is that region.
Make sense?
So then I have a pole at
minus 2 with the right sided.
OK, so that's this.
And a pole as 2,
which is left sided.
So that's this.
So that corresponds
to a region here.
Then the third one I have a
pole at minus 2, which is left
sided.
So that means I want to
have convergence here.
And I have a pole at 2
which is right sided,
and I need convergence here.
There's no way to
make that convergent.
If I choose my s to make the
first part convergent then
my second part is not
convergent, and vice versa.
So there's no way
to do that one.
So this is no.
This is yes.
And then finally, this is a
pole at minus 2 to the left.
And a pole at 2 to the left.
So that's that one.
So that's OK.
So the idea is that there's
only three ways to chop up
a space delimited by two poles.
OK, so it looks like
you to have four
because we're used to thinking
about the two by two matrix.
That's not the way it works.
OK, two last things.
First last thing.
Probably the most
important thing
about the Laplace transform,
probably the only reason
we bother with that whatever
is that you can use it to solve
differential equations.
That's probably the
most important reason
for even talking about it.
The fact that we can take
it is of zero consequence.
We can take lots of integrals.
The interesting thing
about this integral
is that it helps us to solve
differential equations.
And the trick is that if we
start with the differential
equation we can take
the Laplace transform
of the whole
differential equation
and that will end
up making sense.
Just like the z transform, the
Laplace transform is linear.
The Laplace
transform of a sum is
sum of the Laplace transforms.
That's pretty simple just
by looking at the definition
because we can distribute the
e to the minus st over a sum,
if x were a sum it distributes.
So that's easy.
The other important
thing is the derivative.
What's the Laplace
transform of a derivative?
That turns out to be easy.
If that weren't easy, we
wouldn't even bother with it.
But it is easy.
You can see that if we
make the assumption that x
is the Laplace transform
of x, and then if we define
y is the derivative
of x, we can ask
what's the Laplace
transform of y
and that will tell
us what's the Laplace
transform of the derivative.
Take the definition
of transform,
stick in y equals x dot
and integrate by parts.
You all can integrate
by parts much better
than I can because I
took it 35 years ago.
But it's very easy to see that
if we call this u and this v
dot, integral u dv is uv
minus the integral v du.
The trick is that taking
integrals and derivatives
of this part is easy,
it's an exponential.
Exponentials are
the one function
whose derivative has the
same shape as the function.
That's the reason it's easy.
So that means that I can
easily integrate that part.
I can easily
differentiate that part
to get something that looks just
like this, except as multiplied
by minus s.
And that minus s
is the only thing
that ends up being important.
The Laplace transform
of the derivative
is s times the Laplace transform
of the original function.
OK, differentiating
time is the same
as multiplying by s in
a Laplace transform.
Because of that it's
trivial to think
about the Laplace transform
of a differential equation.
Linearity says you
can do it term wise.
And a differential
equation is something
that has a bunch of
derivatives in it.
Those all turn
into multiply by s.
So you end up then with
this differential equation
being replaced by this.
So the Laplace transform of
the derivative is s times y.
The Laplace transform of y is y.
Now I have to figure out the
Laplace transform of delta.
OK, turns out that's easy.
What's the Laplace
transform of delta?
That's why we like
delta functions.
Delta functions seem
mathematically bizarre
but they're so
easy to work with,
that's the only
reason we use them.
If you think about the
Laplace transform of delta
just stick it in the formula.
The interesting thing
about the delta function
is that it's 0
almost everywhere.
So we don't need to
worry about the product
except where the delta
function is not 0.
Because the delta function
makes the time axis mostly 0.
The only place
that's not 0 is 0.
So the only value of this
function that matters
in the least is its value at 0.
If you think about what that
looks like is as a picture.
So if we have something that
looks like e to the minus st
and if we multiply
by an impulse.
The impulse is 0 except at 0.
The only thing that
survives that multiplication
is the value of e to the
minus st at t equals 0.
We can think about
that as a limit.
We thought about
the delta function
as a limit of a function that
looks like this, minus epsilon,
epsilon t, 1 over 2 epsilon.
So that the limit as epsilon
goes to 0 becomes a delta.
That's how we defined
the impulse function.
If we think about that
definition in terms
of this product you
can see that you
get exactly this expression.
So if you multiply this
times this all you pick out
is this part.
As you make epsilon smaller,
and smaller, and smaller,
you focus just on
that point right at 0.
The area of the impulse is 1.
Therefore, the integral of
this thing is everywhere 1.
So this sifts out.
That's what we'll call it.
So this is called
the sifting property.
It's the nice part about
the delta function.
If you integrate a
function with regard
to time where the function
is multiplied by delta,
that integral is the value
of the function at 0.
It sifts out the 0 value.
That means that the Laplace
transform of the delta function
is 1.
It's the most simple
function you can imagine.
So the net effect of that
is that this differential
equation, the Laplace transform
of the differential equation
becomes an algebraic equation.
That means that we can
solve it by doing algebra.
So in particular, we can
readily solve the equation
to find an expression for y.
We saw that previously.
We recognize ys.
It's a recognition thing.
It's a table look
up sort of thing.
We know the form
1 over s plus 1.
So we know the time
function that is the answer.
So notice that when
we do this just
the way that happened
with the z transform.
When we solve a
differential equation
by using Laplace transform we
basically don't use calculus.
We use the Laplace transform
to turn the differential
equation which is calculus in
1803 and that kind of stuff,
into algebra, which
is high school.
We do everything with algebra.
The only annoying thing is
this table look up thing.
It's a little
annoying that we had
to do the inverse Laplace
transform by table look up.
It's a little dissatisfying.
So I'll just mention that
there is a formal way of not
doing table look up.
For the kinds of
problems we will
look at using this
formula is so much more
difficult than table look
up that we will never
use that formula.
It will be useful
for proving things,
it will not be useful
for inverting things.
Because of the
form of the things
we do, linear
differential equations
with constant coefficients,
it will always
be easier to do
table look up then
it will be to run this integral.
If you're interested in that
integral, fine, take 1804.
There's a bunch of
people who know all
about how that integral works.
It's spectacularly interesting
but we won't use it here.
So the upshot then is that
the Laplace transform,
we learn about it
because it's very useful
and its utility comes from
a bunch of properties.
The ones we illustrated
today, we use the fact
that it was linear
and we use the fact
that there's a
simple relationship
with differentiation.
Using just those facts
it turns out easy
to do differential equations
using the Laplace transform.
And there's many
other things I've
illustrated in the
last two slides
but I won't go over
them right now.
The idea of taking limits
using Laplace transforms.
It turns out that the
Laplace transform is what
we call a reciprocal function.
Since the integrand depends
and the product of s and t,
s gets large, corresponds
to t gets small.
So you can take the
limit for things
with time getting small by
looking at s getting big.
Similarly, you can
do the reverse.
You can look at time gets big
by looking at s gets small.
That's just properties
of the Laplace transform.
And there's lots of others.
Besides the table there's
lots of properties
we won't have time
to go over but I
will hint at some of them.
And in particular, there's
a very useful transformation
where you take the Laplace
transform of a circuit.
And that's in the homework.
So that's extremely useful.
The major point then
is just that there's
lots of relationships,
there's lots of ways
we think about CT systems.
This Laplace
transform is a new one
and it's very useful because of
the properties in that table.
OK, thanks a lot.